hi guys this is a list of the top five
worst childhoods in all of my hero
academia childhoods are ranked based on
two factors firstly how tragic the
childhood is and secondly how much
information we actually have about that
character this is because there are some
examples of characters who have the
tragic back stories like kamilly woods
but we just don't have enough
information about them for them to be on
this list if you love my year academia I
have two new videos coming up that I've
already recorded including the top ten
characters with elemental quirks and the
top five all my death theories that's in
addition to my videos already on this
channel including one where I rank the
top eight characters with multiple
quirks with all of that out of the way
let's get to the list at fifth place we
have a character who appeared in the
very first page of the manga and has a
few flashback cameos two rather anime
his name if you didn't know which you
probably didn't given that even I didn't
know his name is Tsubasa
Tsubasa was a childhood friend of Bach
ago he was a small chubby boy who had a
quirk that gave him a pair of giant red
wings that allowed him to fly the name
Tsubasa also means wings in Japanese
which is clearly a reference to his
quirk his grandfather was dr. Tsubasa
this doctor is also the mastermind
behind creating the creatures known as
no mousse and he is basically a faithful
servant of all for one during the hero
killer arc of the anime a wings no move
appears out of nowhere and out of
everybody in the crowd it specifically
swoops down and picks up Deku who was
far from being the easiest target at the
time most people wouldn't afford any
deeper into him however in a bonus page
in volume 7 of the manga it was
confirmed by Hiroshi that the reason
this nomu singled out Deku was because
this creature was in fact young Tsubasa
this means that at some point
dr. Tsubasa found his own grandson into
a no move meaning that this kid is the
only person on this list to actually
have been killed off permanently what's
even sadder is that he clearly retains
some of his humanity the fact he chose
to pick up Deku essentially proves this
he recognizes the Deku and was reaching
out to him in the best way he could
given that no Musab basically incapable
of real speech although Tsubasa was a
belief he did not deserve to go out like
that seriously
he was eventually stabbed in the brain
by the hero killer and that was the end
of him so pretty brutal way to go out a
fourth place on the list is fan favorite
show Totoro ki if you've seen an anime
you know that Shoto had an absolutely
trashed childhood which left him with a
severe burn on his face and
relationship with his dad Shoto his very
existence was the result of a forced
quark marriage so already he's not off
to a good start his dad wanted to create
a child with the perfect work that would
have the potential to be the number one
hero in that respect Shoto siblings
never lived up to this expectation and
we're allowed to actually have what
appears to be a semi-normal childhood at
the very least we know they got to play
ball games Shoto meanwhile due to his
overpowered quark was resigned to a
childhood of training like all the time
the second he turned five years old he
began training and even when he was
throwing up on the floor his father
would simply turned to stop pretending
on top of this endeavor was a domestic
abuser and would frequently beat shut
his mother in front of Rosa particularly
when she tried to intervene with his
rigorous training this eventually led to
a form of mental breakdown in which he
threw boiling water over the left side
of show to his face which of course is
the fire side that he inherited from
endeavour she could barely even look at
her son at that point after this shota's
mother was taken away and he would never
see her again until he was a teenager
and on top of this for some ridiculous
reason endeavour prevented Shoto from
interacting with his older siblings
which is probably why shadow didn't
recognize this guy at all so because of
all of this combined shota's childhood
was in absolute shambles this terrible
upbringing lets him having a very cold
personality and rejecting his father
completely which is why of course in
season 1 he only used the I side of his
body he became cold and distant from
people by virtue of his childhood
however he has become much more likable
recently and I think a lot of that can
be attributed to his Ooka Midori as
influence on him in third place is
another character that Deku has greatly
influenced perhaps to an even greater
extent and that character's name is Kota
Kota is a small boy who was introduced
to us in season 3 who is quite a
reserved character and hates pretty much
everything to do with super human
society but the reason he has this
worldview is because of his enormous Lea
terrible childhood
kotas parents were a pro hero team known
as waters when Kota was 3 they were both
killed by the villain known as muscular
this event made Kota an orphan at an
incredibly young age then only two years
later at the age of five years old the
villain that murdered both of his
parents finds him in the woods and
literally attempts to murder him as well
and if it wasn't for Deku Kota literally
would have been killed like there's no
question about it think of how much
trauma this boy's had to go through
first he was orphaned and
he was a victim of attempted murder by
the person who made him an orphan
however despite this his character has
seemed to warm up a little bit it now
appears that he idolizes deku to a
degree if you've read the Maggie you'll
know what I'm talking about but I could
definitely pick from doing an internship
with deco in the future or maybe even
potentially being a sidekick okay so now
we're about to go into genuine spoiler
territory so if you're anime only then I
suggest you subscribe and come back to
this video when you're fully caught up
or if you don't mind hearing spoilers I
mean these are essentially just
backstories they don't affect the
current plot per se so so it's really up
to you though that being said the
character number one has never been
shown in the anime yet until season four
so you may just want to wait for that at
number two on this list we have the
leader of the league of villains tenko
Shimura more commonly known as tomorrow
sugar Aki his childhood is actually the
focus of the manga at the moment and as
we've been seeing in several flashbacks
for several chapters now we have a
pretty clear idea of what happened to
him as a child but I personally think
that there's still a few things to be
revealed
regarding all for one's involvement but
going off what we know currently his
childhood was nothing short of
horrendous growing up young 10-car was a
kind child who evidently looked up to
all might to some degree however his
father hated superheroes with a passion
and refused to even let the topic be
discussed in his house for that reason
he frequently abused Tenko we've seen
10-codes father lock him outside the
house and even viciously slap him down
with very minor things things that most
parents would never classify as doing
something wrong but perhaps the most
traumatic thing about Tengu started the
thing that truly makes it one of the
worst in all of my year academia is when
his quirk finally awakened similarly to
Deku Tenko did not develop a quirk at
the age he was supposed to and he kind
of appeared like he wouldn't however it
turns out that what his mother thought
was an allergy was actually the
manifestation of his decaying quirk one
night after a beating from his father
tinkers quark awakened if you've ever
seen my ear academia then you definitely
know this but tankers quote basically
activates when he touches something with
all five fingers when that happens
whatever he's touching basically decays
into nothing however the first time is
quark awakened this was on a completely
different level as he was hugging his
dog it instantly dropped dead then when
his sister came outside he touched her
gently and she literally fell apart in
two different slabs of meat this
continued with the rest of his family
his grandma his grandpa his mom all of
them just fell into cubes of flesh one
by one complete
disappearing this was one of the most
graphic things I'd ever read in my hair
academia I don't think they can animate
that it's just it's too graphic but
we'll have to wait and see having killed
his entire family with his bands with a
quirk that suddenly manifested out of
nowhere it really doesn't get much worse
than that when he killed his father we
could definitely see they did it on
purpose
whereas with his sister and his grandma
and his mom it kind of look like it was
just an accident
however he fully admits later on in the
manga that he did do that on purpose
at least on a subconscious level and
after this happened no one came to help
him for days
he ran away from home and no one came
and reached out to him and that
experience is part of the reason why he
hates here in society people always
assume that a hero is gonna help those
in need and thus no one helps because
they assume a hero will do it and of
course no one did show up to help young
Tenko until all for one did as the
audience we know that all for one groom
tenko to be successor basically just to
mess with all my as he obviously knew
that the boy was the grandchild of
Almighty master known as Shimura partly
for that reason I'm pretty sure that
down the line it will be revealed that
tenko was initially Quercus and awful
one gave him the decay quark and just
another point I'd like to make in my
hair academia it is pretty clear that
the nature of someone's quark can affect
their personality we've seen this with
characters like toga and Todoroki I told
her okay she was of course a very cold
person when we first met him which is
kind of metaphoric for the fact that at
that time he only used his icy cold side
you could also say the same for back ago
who has a very explosive personality and
his quirk is obviously explosion in that
same vein of the decay quark which I
believe was given to tanker by all-4-one
altered his personality in a way that
made him lust for destruction given that
when we see tanker when he's a young kid
before he manifests is quite he's very
kind and caring but after his quite
manifest itself suddenly he only wants
to destroy it regardless of whether this
is the case or not when you're abused by
your father and you killed your entire
family with your unstable quark
essentially by accident although he
later admits it was partly intentional
and then on top of that all essentially
being kidnapped and groomed by the worst
villain on earth that's a pretty crappy
upbringing especially for someone who
desired to be a hero that's probably the
worst I'll bring you could have now
finally in first place the character
with the worst childhood in the history
of my hero academia is of course if you
read them
arrey will soon be seeing a lot of Aries
childhood in season 4 this is a girl
who's been repeatedly experimented on
killed only to be brought back to life
and have the same thing done over and
over but for a bit of context I'm just
gonna lay the groundwork here area is
the granddaughter of the head of a
criminal organization at a young age
much like sugar aki she accidentally
manifested her new quirk and used it on
her father which caused him to literally
disappear her power resembled nothing
from either side of her family so her
mother believed that her existence was
cursed and gave the girl up to her
grandfather the grandfather then left
his granddaughter in the care of his
protege whose name is Kasia Saki
otherwise known as overhaul he did this
so that overhaul could identify the
girls quark and this is where things
started to go wrong after her
grandfather fell into a critical state
of illness overhaul basically took over
the organization and began to experiment
on arey
to turn Houck work into a weapon this
enabled him to manufacture quark
destroying bullets initially they were
temporary in that they would temporarily
erase someone's quark but eventually he
did perfect the perfect bullet that
could permanently erase someone's quark
but in order to do this he had to
destroy arey collect our blood and then
repair her he did this hundreds upon
thousands of times
imagine being killed hundreds of
thousands of times over and over again
and now I'm gonna get into some actual
spoilers about the plot of season 4 so
if you enjoyed this video please pause
it right now if you don't want to his
poised for season 4 please like it and
share it on social media I'd really
appreciate it now for those of you who
don't care about spoilers for season 4
every does eventually escape overhauls
imprisonment but to be fair I don't
think anything can make up for the the
madness that she's gone through the best
student aua miryo - gotta not only gave
up is quark to save this girl but he
seems to have taken on some sort of
fatherly duties and raising her in time
she will master her very dangerous quark
but given that she's living at UA I have
no doubt in my mind that she will
eventually become a student there when
the time is right with people like Deku
miryo and Aizawa all seemingly willing
to help raise her now
there's definitely a bright future for
her but in terms of her childhood being
abandoned by her mother erasing her
father from existence being killed and
resurrected by overhaul millions of
times and then obviously causing miryo
you know the best you may you a to lose
his
quirk every deserves this number one
spot for wash childhood in history and
there you have it
that was the list of the five worst
childhoods in my hero academia if you
can think of anyone I've missed out or
someone you think deserves to be on this
list please let me know thank you for
watching and don't forget to check out
my top eight video from the other week
if you want to check that out it's
called top eight characters with
multiple quirks I'd like to give a shout
out to everyone who tweeted or retweeted
that video last week their name should
be on the screen or specifically their
Twitter handles not their names and if
you like this video please subscribe
like I said I have two more videos
already recorded got at least one at
least one next week but if you subscribe
and click the belt again notified you'll
see them regardless peace